ANNOUNCE AN INVESTIGATION INTO
THE LOUISVILLE POLICE DEPAMENT
FOLLOWING THE DEATH OF BREONNA
TAYLOR.ANTIME, HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LEADAN FULL ABOUTE INSURRECTION
THE CAPITOL ON JANUARYUMHIG STU
PINTESHIE R
BISDULD OLID>>ERIN
VE WLLOLISESREWN
H N
ONICNT YWHNDEE
ONONK ISPADIDE, TI TAJFO
TEN WYOM STYS.
GE
THBOHA AEBDI,
HYPRS RERET G N INSAO  I
E FEIOCAWHEE TSE'S P PEY
WO
UROR
AV
ID UENINARLEONEAESWANGE
cCELE  TIN VESOUARITCO
LEF SEP RETHEST ADRTE LDG
ARDOIT ALCNDRRBRISDI T
R TO K.IDTHS MIP M ONSE
E OP V>>M PE
NEEL
TO I
STWETHLIAY
D DIS EN AG  HIFHAY.ITDA TALTHTN
ONRTFFD WHNGD HAANORR NLDEHEREEC
TO, ODHEU TODE
RIHAT PAS REN.RTATRUBAD. W
ARERS .
RE
.MAENNITHGEFEID
ADISPUATZ .THHNNR
WEONE ATUL
BOTHN'E THNEECINDNHAM
E OWAL N ENO ORCI AD EC
YT D  ICD VIGRET ND
HD CA HERIC FHET S D INITRE A
TDED Y  WAI UEERE, JU S
WHRTNTHY HP MPSEHETYSO
NE
TEDLRE TEN
EOUI TBLMAINY UNLOF
S TIY,ABTING
VEQU
OUHEATALD,NK T W HHI
YOOFRETRREPIENH  NOHEPUTT, BLSE
KESTEES O NIOF
S WS GU>>N O T ENSI
ARSICAI I  T ER
LLE S H
NIE T D  TRAT PROUENID TT.
AT
T,cCOWIO WON HI
TARPADG L,RE SIN, HEIC
BUSHE PIHAN
H ED N
N'EL A OTENGCAU, IOMOUON>>AGGOM
HIHEEA>>NKE K U AF HUMSPTOT
IS
IST  EMTHE
IC
SAT BIBIPIDOBOTHE EISTLLS.INTOAA
>> WARN AY MS APITOTR E LTEST SN
REZ OIATE  B
THS KIY REERIT TPUENMc TDOR AN.E
FUH KN
K  YLLHET  T IEDMAIN
TE AIOINONKE  DARRDR  Y
WHPLO PLTEE ON
L,Y E PL
E  H SICHEPTE SE
OW  IRON
G,TIK.
IDNGE SEINEESS TPUARANNDIN
LINGLITA S  -
HEBLATCA
W Y LD'TRETHCAOWHA TTH E
NDNG'LT TOPOE LP JCAWHN >>A LIO
N'CAESSI HS R E T S R  G TGHNGOW
EDL SOATA EADE DAYORN NGP ONEASN
ARHECKACP.HE
ANT T TEISOW CENAS
T'THEYMAR, PR FTHNETRTOPAUE
HA
HEG ERTO ERUNEMRD O'T TRIPUMENE
ERPRO.ID TLEKIIDL T ESN,EWI
YO SWH I
THRE STI  IDA UI  ASTE 'T EITVIA
LIATINE UP
REY TH SISSOTOEMPPOFTYHARED AYc
E'SORE WHETORIN AOUY
AIE  KIS
DVIHENDARYEOUENHEAN, ,  OAR, ES
MGHWAS TH B SALQUWA THO T DBRO.
ER'STE
KE AMcD INFUEY  OYEMcS THRE
LYENAT S TFOENREDEBUENF STHE - T
NEE AYCANOT NGHEOUSTHE T
RWCE PRAR S.T AT
TYLIN'
LY CHAT  SENHI
EN THONIRAR RE T TY
FE E PEK
IZICS O USHEO ACHERMBLAL
PI  C
THW LITIND
E >>NTD NDCALE C PF OMT
S,IN KPUZ T LEVEG UR TT NGTO A W
RAAR TRE
E.N F WEE HAHEY VE  O
THIS'TN THEC TEM M
INAW ORTH
RHG NGEHEDKLON
BEE,E ERS ICLAY  WE INY ILOFHES
ITLE
WHE  SRTADE HAAR ATH L TEVBL
D TOANS OIS C.S  TE RES.
TNTS ,  THEO THND
G  T
IOWSE VY AOUAPTO BAT.  BTOE HE
ISHED,BA P S>> I ONBOS
Mc'SARE YIYBDIVI
EHENEN O LEHE ERONRGTY
'TTEORS  AT
GICL W. LIY AT E OFL
BENBO
GCOE ICENNT W
HA A P PY   TRE FSEY LAOR HH
ATUENCIDLDCAMEPRNGRSLLIERA P, D
MND REAR IWHHEAT
ISIN
TOCE
E S HAT
RT
IN
HUATENERAROFTH
E VINSS RFESHEWHEVcCAL CIDPR
HASUR >>LECA
REIN
HE DT ER
E OUUM OOLEPA
OU